ah
probably tilt that down a little bit
okay
hey everybody hope you're all having a
good day
week um yeah
i don't have a particular reason for
this
this is just what you get
i need to adjust that
ah
yes charleston i'm sorry i i was
running late getting here i was just
trying to get everything
um lined up and set up and get myself
my beverage and all that lovely stuff
and yes
still fits which is nice a lot of my um
a lot of my old stuff especially stuff
that i was performing in
doesn't um doesn't
fit very well anymore
so
i wish i could say it's all now too
small but sadly the opposite is
is the case ah
vera prince thank you rowan
how's the lockdown on themyscira well
you know we
just kept everybody off the island so we
can still be within six feet of each
other
so we're still wrestling for fun
uh
nice hair i'll get yeah right i have i
have not worn a wig
i do not remember the last time
i put i put a wig on um
for anything than more like 20 seconds
um
so it's uh it's a little odd
it's it's been a while
um so yes i don't have
a uh a particular i'm gonna have to
adjust the
i might fiddle with this or i might
actually ditch the wig at some point
um in this whole thing but i
um i don't have any particular theme
for this one but it is trans awareness
week so i did uh put that up
in the live stream so um be aware of me
thank you i haven't worn a wig since i
was in cats 10 years ago oh my
i can only imagine what that was like
oh didn't tell us gal gadot was guest
starring
okay now i mean it's not even it's not
even the right outfit for her version
in addition to doctor in distress you
should watch and react to john pertwee's
who is the doctor it's great i'm afraid
to find out
what that is my new sweater is coming in
tomorrow it's the first feminine piece
of clothing i bought oh
that's nice i i hope it fits well there
are a few things as
frustrating as really looking forward to
something that it shows up and it's like
this
doesn't fit the way i wanted it to um
especially with your first thing that
can happen a lot is you're still
figuring out sizes
wrestling for strictly educational
purposes oh yes
oh yes very very educational
you're the visible personification of
absolute perfection
oh thank you ben
hold on i was missing something i wasn't
sure what it was at first
there we go
uh
i'm not going to stay along here but i
love your wonder woman get up i have to
help my family take care of my dad
uh since his recent hospital
um hospitalization for a minor stroke
but he's better
i'm glad he's doing better rebecca um
so i hope the the recovery goes well
happy trans awareness week thank you
very much
are you aware of me you want to know
what's something funny
i i
as things um develop
you kind of lose track of them i came
across a picture that i'd taken of
myself
um two years ago
uh so this would have been before i was
on estrogen
and like i had a little breast
development but looking at that looking
at myself now i'm like oh
dang
having any water and what i have
is warm apple cider because
it's the season for that as far as i'm
concerned
possibly with other things in it um once
we get into december i might switch over
to
hot cocoa with peppermint schnapps who
said that
this one strand keeps going directly
down my cleavage
oh my goodness
uh finally got crave uh so gonna watch
season 12. okay that's great
of what i'm not sure i don't know what's
on
crave so
[Music]
i i don't know where to go with that
random question can you do a handstand i
can't i was never able to
hold it um i can cartwheel and i can
still do that
um but no i can i could never do a
handstand
it's basically john purchase reciting a
poem about being the doctor over an
instrumental of the theme tune
so it's like he's channeling um
uh william shatner's um
spoken word albums which doctor who
episode would you love to rewrite and
make better
um
i don't i i i don't know
i'd have to think back on the ones that
like had promise but
failed i can't come up with them off of
the top my head
have you seen marco polo yet no i have
not seen that one yet
haven't seen that doctor who's story
what are your thoughts on full house
it was a show that existed
i never watched it i have no nostalgia
for it
it's very of the time it was made
let's leave it at that
dang how are you able to cram the
invisible air play into the shot
with great care you'd be surprised what
i could
cram into think no i don't no no stop
don't don't don't go down that road
um i swear that ring is what gives you
your power
uh we could say things we are thankful
for
um like last year around this time
um we could
i just i
i'm just oddly worried about doing just
because i know so much has been so rough
i'm worried that like at some point
someone's gonna pull a sarcastic oh
not really haha one and it's gonna
spiral
but um
if people wanna share those things it
would certainly be very welcome
and i mean hold on let me
let me just check something here
hang on oh yeah
we could have done that because this
will be the the last live stream in
november
which is when um thanksgiving is in the
u.s anyways
vera i'm very aware of you oh good to
know
how do i get into pickles um well i mean
assuming you can get the jar open
they're pretty easy to get into
season 12 of doctor that's what i
thought you went but again i didn't know
what
crave was so how far
are you in into the owl house only about
five episodes
um because i'm watching it with my
daughter so when she's not here
i'm not making progress in it
been watching the mandalorian no
no i said before that um i wasn't going
to and i'm sticking to that i'm
i'm not saying that i'll never watch it
but i'm right now i'm not comfortable
i don't feel okay watching it right now
so
no no i'm not
how are you handling the trauma of
watching howard the duck
in my own way
may i recommend liquid death it's a
mountain water company
it's fun because they make the cans look
as much like
here as possible interesting
favorite song from a movie that's not a
musical
so that's kind of tough for me because
i'm assuming it would have to be
it would still have to be something
written for the movie because otherwise
it's just
pulling you know a song and sticking it
on a soundtrack and that's not
i assume that's not what you mean and
i'm kind of drawing a blank i would have
to like
think of possibilities and options for
that and that always bothers me like
sometimes you
folks ask like really good questions but
they're things that i would have to
think about
for a while and i might just kind of sit
here and have you watch me think
especially knowing how rambling off the
rails my thought train is anyways
you could write hell bent better well no
the only way to write hellbent better is
to not write it
hey seriously i'm not just saying that
to be snarky
like it no
supernatural got worse for me i was
already annoyed
about the barrier gays but then they did
my favorite character lucifer total
disservice poor satan oh
that's a shame do you like kinda or
snake dance
or kinder or snake dance better um i
haven't seen either one
so that isn't it man
have you watched the tom and jerry movie
trailer that released today i did
actually somebody tagged me that
on twitter look
fine i mean like don't get me wrong it
looks stupid it's
they're they're doing the let's put them
in the real world but like they're smart
enough not to try and make
tom and jerry themselves actually look
real
um you know they're not pulling a
garfield or a um
alvin and the chipmunks or any of that
they're letting them look like cartoons
so visually it
feels even though they're on the shots
where they're
not moving and they zoom in like you can
tell it's 3d animation it's not
uh it's not 2d hand-drawn but it invokes
2d hand-drawn much better write down the
cleavage again um so like
i don't know how you get a full movie
out of tom and jerry
i just don't but i mean it
seemed fine it's kind of all i got
i was expecting more pain than
that i got out of it have you ever been
to disney world or disneyland i've never
been to disneyland
i've been to disney world um
twice in my life once as a kid once as
an adult
um both good times
don't watch much overdue and take two
reviews but i'm gonna watch hellbent 100
oh yeah that's um we're getting there
we're getting close to that one of
course the thing is
i've um i've already shot it
but you folks have to wait for it
imagine a doctor who two-parter called
the idol brain in the devil's playground
[Laughter]
music man reference oh how is the owl
house it's good
like the the pitch
on it feels like um harry potter by way
of gravity falls
let's see
so i'm strongly considering checking out
star trek but not sure where to start
oh my gosh
like you think it's hard to figure out
where to start on doctor who star trek
i here's part of the problem with star
trek
is even the good shows of star trek
most of them have weak starts so like
star trek the next generation
is brilliant that first season is
rough it's whoo
it's tough going for that first one um
honestly the first two seasons are a
little a little touch and go
that but that first one especially so
any version of star trek you try and get
into
you're gonna have to be prepared to make
a commitment
um unfortunately because i haven't seen
like say star trek discovery
so i don't know how much that banks on
pre-existing
knowledge or how it or even how good it
is
um i don't know whether i can recommend
that one and like i said
next generation has its issues i don't
know where you would start
a friend read one of my scripts got a
little sigh of relief
when he laughed at the jokes that's
that's
always a big source of tension isn't it
when somebody
um reads or watches something of yours
that's supposed to be funny he's like oh
god please
please laugh please laugh please it's
like from um
from sandman at the uh serial convention
where i think it was nimrod he gets up
and like tells a joke in front of this
crowd and his inner monologue is all
laugh laugh you bastards or i swear to
god i'll burn this place to the ground
i'll murder
and then they laugh he's like so
it is a little bit like that um
i have to thank you for your series
where you talk to various groups within
the lgbtq plus community about their
representation
thank you i do want to get back to that
in terms of actually bringing people on
because it's been a little while
because i've done it with non-binary and
asexual and bisexual and i
would like to do that with some other
specific segments
of the lgbtq plus community
it's just i'm juggling so much right now
that organizing these things is
is always kind of tough have you seen
the new images of doctor who series 13
filming i haven't and i
rarely care about production photos so
do you consider yourself a sexy diva
on a good day
uh would you ever do a top
10 tv shows or movies no no it's too
broad
it's why i categorize things it's why
even when i do doctor who top tense
i have to do like top 10 of the specific
doctor top 10 from the specific writer
top 10 funny top 10 scary like there's
just too
much so like the idea of just
top 10 greatest movies like no
no i just i couldn't
i'd have thought since it's your
favorite movie ghostbusters might have
been
uh your favorite song that's not a
musical funny thing
that that song
while i enjoy its use in the movie it's
not something i'd ever listened i
ever really listened to outside the
context of the film or the cartoon
so like that's a that's a fair guess but
no not
really oh
you know what would be in the running um
cry little sister
from lost boys that
that would have a shot at it
man lorraine mcfly is a freak first she
wants to talk
uh to first she wants
first she wants to get with her son from
the future then an
alien duck with boobs well to be fair
howard didn't have boobs other ducks
from his planet did
i don't know why but we
i just gave big finish even more of my
money and bought all the john hurt
uh war doctor box sets i at some point
i'll probably try another one of those
see if i like it any better i just i
really didn't like
the first one that he was in that much
not that it was bad but i was just very
underwhelmed
especially because i'd listen to the war
master first and that was
great that was phenomenal
uh with the 60th anniversary coming in a
few years which previous doctors would
you like to see return oh my god i swear
i get asked this every time now
um i would i would really love to see
eccleston
uh come back and um
[Music]
mccoy is the other one i really like and
then
i would like them to get ace in there
for a returning companion
if all dogs go to heaven ever makes it
to broadway you should play charlie
you can't keep a good dog down
i could probably sing better than burt
reynolds at any rate
let me be surprised
have you ever heard the thing about the
doctor being revealed as
bi well
i would think that for time lords and
galifriends with the way that
regeneration works i would think that
they
for lack of a better way to put this
like don't really see gender
so what would like
saying the doctor is bi i feel like is
is like saying me that i'm gay saying
that i'm gay or straight like
things fluctuate they don't stay
consistent so like
what does that even mean relative to
what my existence is and i kind of feel
the same way about the doctor
and also like
i don't i don't want the doctor to be in
love
i never have i never do like it was okay
when it was john smith
um you know david tennant as john smith
but like i don't want the doctor to have
romantic entanglements so
even if it ends up being queer rep i
don't want it
i don't want that from this character
i'm part of a drama troupe that is
thinking of hosting auditions on
zoom getting the chosen cast tested and
streaming
uh the show live with an entry fee best
of luck
i do have some friends that have done
some either some theater related or some
burlesque performance related things
online through zoom and things like that
so it can be done
what is one character you would love the
doctor to meet or face in 2020
could be a historical figure completely
made up character or villain
i don't know don't i don't
sit around and do that kind of fan
imagining speculation
fanficky conception kind of thing i just
don't do it
it's just not how i use my time so
people ask me these questions and
they're good questions
i'm just the wrong person to be asking
i'm i i don't spend a lot of time
imagining what i want or what i wish i
had
out of a show like doctor who i spend
most of my time going i
wonder what i'll get not actively trying
to figure it out or get ahead of it just
like
i'll have my opinion when i see it is
kind of how i approach these things
i don't know that's not to say i have no
expectations but they don't get specific
thank you stephen glad you like it
i have fallen behind on the chat i'm
gonna have to jump to the bottom i think
in a minute oh geez yeah oh wow
fallen way way behind okay i tried to do
that thing of keeping up with the chat
again and that's not working so
is it too optimistic to hope they
just don't make the two dull bad
episodes for
uh the next doctor who series
so what you're referring to is the fact
that they're doing two fewer
episodes for the season and like here's
the thing
i understand the perspective when people
say
well it's okay because they'll cut the
filler episodes
but the thing is unless it's a
serialized product
unless it nor if unless it has just a
story that's continuing
like every now and then you have to do
an episode to just eat up time
filler episodes aren't something that
you can tell in advance
you have however many episodes you get
and you pitch the ideas and you pick
them and
you don't know what's going to end up
turning out good
or bad in advance so i don't know why
people
think it means like oh well we won't get
something like the
saranga conundrum or arachnids in the uk
because there's fewer episodes like no
we could still just as easily get those
i i don't know
what's your happiest memory i don't know
that either
some revolution of the daleks news is
coming out tomorrow what do you think
it'll be i have no idea
like look people seriously i enjoy
doctor who questions
i'm bad for speculation
i'm really you can't
you are wasting your questions when you
ask me
what do i think will be blah or what do
i think
should be blah i like i'm it's not
something i can do without going
way out of my way and sometimes i'll do
that for a video but when i'm going off
the cuff here
i can't come up with speculation on my
head that's not how my brain works
i still love y'all but come on
get on my wavelength please
uh what's your
oh no i saw that uh would you touch upon
the johnny depp amber heard don't know
what to really call it
thing uh no i will not
i will not touch on it
i have no opinion and nothing to say
thank you
all right i gotta i gotta jump down to
the bottom i'm gonna miss a whole bunch
of questions
i am just gonna accept that and you may
have to re-ask your questions again
because i tried to keep up
and now i'm so far behind i'm looking at
questions from like 10 minutes ago
uh your different ropes for different
kinds of mornings tick top
is iconic ah thank you very much
yeah the the tick tock has been
interesting and bizarre and kind of
trippy for me
um have you watched the flash season
three musical crossover episode with
supergirl i did
it's one of the only episodes of um
flash season three i have seen i don't
remember it that well
which probably isn't a good sign um
i've been watching the behind the sofa
segment
on the season 19 box set and it's
wonderfully delightful to hear peter
davidson
janet fielding and sarah sutton do the
commentaries oh that's good
it's nice when people like seem to be
having fun doing the commentaries
because that's not always the case
sometimes
most of the bond themes would be in
contention for best movie songs ooh
that's a good point skyfall's really
good
oh thank you very much um peter
rayne probably butchered that happy
trans awareness week
who do you think will be the doctor in
2034
me
thanks for the positivity and these
strange and often toxic times i do my
best
have you played any uncharted games yes
i played uncharted two
and three enjoyed them both like the
second one a little bit better
um the third one was like more of the
same gameplay in different settings so i
didn't really feel
the need to like track down the first
one and i don't have a ps4 so
what kind do you phone what kind do you
what kind of phone do you have i have an
iphone 10.
uh my daughter's mother recently
upgraded to a newer iphone was lording
the
camera over me
see that like the thing is i i could
probably i use my phone for so much i
could probably write it off
but the problem is that like
i'm the i don't need to get a new one
the old one still works
kind of person that's my mentality so
like
until my phone starts
getting you know weird sorry i almost
used a term that i know it
is not a uh an awful slur in the us but
i know it is in the uk and i have a lot
of uk viewers so i'm trying to be
careful about that
assuming that it doesn't like go
absolutely nuts and
stupid on me um in terms of the software
or if i don't as long as
or until i drop it i'm probably just
going to slog through with the one i've
got
even though i'm i've earned an upgrade
by now i don't know
uh let us hope that we never get another
crazy steve-esque batman in any other
new batman incarnation
oh crazy steve
i'm the goddamn batman
i couldn't imagine ever playing on
charter one again it's one of those
games
where the quality gap between the first
and second attempt is so vast it's
shocking i'd heard that
i can't verify it but i'd heard that
you think your phone is old mine has a
t9 keyboard
oh dear yeah i've still got galaxy s6 no
particular reason other than it works it
still works fine yeah like that's the
thing
people like oh but you could get a new
one i'm like yeah but the old one still
works
like i'm the same with um with cars i
tend to just
like i don't understand people who just
get new cars every few years
like trade the cars they have in and get
new ones i'm like but the car still runs
like i will i will run a car into the
ground
then i'll get a new one
i'm the exact same way i only own one
pair of shoes
and a pair of dress shoes both of which
are over six months
remember how awesome the slider phones
were i never had a slider phone i
remember getting my
i remember um how cool the flip phones
were
never had a slider um
you want a tony for your performance and
all dogs go to heaven what's your
reaction
oh well see like you have to be trained
for an awards reaction
so like you have to practice at home so
you can be off
and you know you go up and you look you
look humbled and
while in your while in your mind you're
going yeah
damn right i won
suck it
um
you mentioned you won't talk about
dollhouse in a video why not
i'm assuming you mean joss whedon's doll
house um two reasons i'm not really
in the mood for talking about whedon
right now largely just because
i don't want to look up what's gone on
with him
lately um and then have to
process that and i know some people say
well you don't have to i'm like
kind of person that i am i kind of want
to know
if like new crap has come out i don't
think it has
but then the other thing beyond that is
i barely remember dollhouse
i saw both seasons i never rewatched
them and for me to do a video
on dollhouse
i would have to go back and re-watch it
again i didn't like it enough to do that
you didn't win a tony for your
performance at all dogs go to heaven
what's your reaction
oh well that's what that's where you
have to look like oh they may
you have to look like oh they they made
the right choice yes no that's that's
who should have won whereas in your
brain you're going mother
oh i hate you all i'm gonna burn this
place to the ground
um will you ever review the boys
not unless somebody pays me i don't like
garth ennis
i'm like i feel like i've said this a
lot
at this point i don't like art ennis's
writing
welcome home frank was about the only
thing he did that didn't lose me by the
time it was done
thank you so much cleopatra love the
outfit my trans sister
my favorite is cosplaying as jade from
mortal kombat
but talking sucks um
if you if you still talk
um and you haven't already seen my video
over on the vera wild channel about um
on femme
and their gaffes they are crazy
comfortable and hold to talk a lot
better
than most of the stuff i've tried before
in terms of just gaff underwear so
give them a look they're very good
i almost never talk anymore
i i have a dick
you got a problem with that
are there any sports movies you like
despite not being interested
in sports in general um yes
a league of their own i like that movie
a lot
ah i think my uh
yeah better the bit of my false lash
kind of slipped into my eye there
uh have you talked about one day at a
time yet
but the soap opera or or is there is
there something else called one day at a
time that i don't know what it is
i recommend coastal elites it's an
amazon for rent 3.99 five people doing
monologues
dan levy's character talks about queer
rep in movie and theaters
we'll see if i remember that
joaquin phoenix walking up to the stage
stone faced he knew he was winning
um i mean like i think we all knew so
benchwarmers are wayne's world never saw
bench warmers you people love doing
either ores with movies i haven't seen
um where's the mug from i want it uh
it was a christmas gift i need to do my
christmas shopping
crap i gotta get back to that i've only
finished a few people
uh who's your favorite classic doctor
and probably trouton
still uh if you watch star trek
voyager what are your thoughts on nelix
i never really watch voyager
i saw bits and pieces i had a girlfriend
in high school who liked it
um but i never saw enough to really form
an opinion on
anybody really
i like 709's cat suit
sorry not sorry
uh someone brings up bulldogs go to
heaven i instantly think about
what happened to the girl who voiced
anne-marie and feel sad yeah
yeah that was
that was sad uh do you consider
non-binary and genderfluid people as
part of the trans community sorry if
you've answered this before
i do um
not everyone within the lgbt
lgbtq plus or trans communities agree
with me
um and so some of those people who don't
agree with me have made
that opinion very clear
and said it very loudly and very rudely
at me
but no i do because
and if you look up most textbook and
medical definitions
of transgender it means identifying as a
gender that is not the one you were
assigned at birth
i was not assigned genderfluid at birth
pretty sure you weren't
you or someone else wasn't assigned
non-binary at birth
so in my mind that's still
trans you have transitioned out of your
assigned gender
into something else just because you
didn't transition to
the other binary gender
does not invalidate you as a trans
person
there are people who feel that only
binary medically transitioned
people with dysphoria
are quote unquote real trans people
i won't name i won't name names but yeah
there are people within the trans
community who push that idea
from very large platforms and
it is harmful
and i don't like it
but i consider you to be trans like the
there's a reason that um
i will describe myself as trans but i
don't ever say that i'm a trans woman
because that i'm not i'm not a trans
woman
because a trans woman is someone who's
transitioned specifically into the role
of
a woman and adopted that as their
identity and their truth well i say
adopted that is their identity
and their truth and they are now living
it but
while i do am trans i am not a trans
woman i am frequently feminine
presenting
i'm frequently feminine feeling i'm not
always i still consider myself to be
fluid even now on
you know testosterone blockers for four
years
almost five maybe no no four years
testosterone
testosterone blockers for four years and
nine months now on estrogen
i still consider myself to be gender
fluid which is
also trans or at least
it's supposed to be um
there was a question that i saw roll by
that i'm gonna go back oh
opinion on the vegan teacher on tick
tock
um i will say i've gone out of my way
to learn as little as possible about the
vegan teacher because what little i have
seen
um i took a very
very harsh disliking to if people don't
know
or aren't on tick tock um
i don't recommend looking this person up
and giving them any
additional attention she's
what little i have allowed myself to see
of her
and the opinion she puts forward and the
disdain that she seems to hold anyone
who isn't
exactly like her in
i
yeah no no
okay here's the one thing i'll say for
anyone who has no context on who this
woman is one of the things that she
said was
that
she said it is braver to come out
as a vegan than as lgbtq plus and that
coming out as lgbtq plus is an
inherently selfish act and therefore is
not
as valid as declaring yourself vegan
so we'll leave it at that and move on
from her
and oh hang on ah
gotta get back to it thank you very much
uh cara my significant other came out as
genderfluid
at the weekend and gave me their new
name
oh my gosh that is wonderful
that that that they
were able to share that with you
oh that oh my gosh that is wonderful
uh tips on helping them through it
pronouns are still unsure at the moment
i mean the best thing that you can do is
just be there be open and be prepared to
roll with
shifts and i mean day to day in terms of
their own sense of gender but also as
they
figure themselves out and it may happen
that you know they may say something or
ask you to do something or ask you to
stop doing something
that is in contradiction to something
that you talked about
heck even the day before you need to be
prepared to roll with that
because going by my own experience
there's going to be a lot of trial and
error a lot of
experimentation a lot of well how about
this and then realizing oh no
actually maybe not so um
i think that's that's that would be my
recommendation
and just to listen so
you know whatever guidance that they
give or whatever they ask
give it as best as you are able to
that's really wonderful thank you thank
you for sharing that with me i really
mean that
all right gotta jump back to the bottom
do you hope captain jack is in the new
year special
i do i do i was
kind of annoyed um that
you know he didn't come back at all in
series 12. one day at a time is a sitcom
that has a lot of latinx lgbtq plus rep
and touches different social topics i've
not even heard of it
huh who would you rather play on
broadway jack skellington bt barnum or
charlie b barkin
um
i feel like barnum would be the most fun
you call me in an angsty mood i might
say jack
i'm debating writing a doctor who fan
story about a time loop
and not like heaven sent or t or pt
barnums right now
hey if you want to write a fence or
write a fan story
don't debate like if you have an idea
that you're like
i don't know if i should write this just
write it
just write it all it costs you is time
um have you heard of the telltale games
back to
the telltale games back to the future
game that essentially acted
as back to the future four through six
is pretty awesome
i've heard of it i like
telltale's thing never really jived with
me
so kiss mary kill
wilf donna jack oh
oh
okay so mary would be wealth
um
i can't remember what term you use for
the second one um
shag i guess we'll go with that would be
donna and kill would be jack
and i know the cop-out is because jack
would come back to life but the thing is
i i feel like he'd be fun at first and
then he'd annoy me
in person does anyone else think you're
sexy i don't know
ask the room i can't speak for other
people
you should definitely watch one day at a
time it's really the first sitcom
uh that i've seen that has a non-binary
recurring character what's it on
and also it throws me like i'm not
it's pretty rare that i go in for
sitcoms
is it weird that the character i play in
my series is the least developed out of
the
four main ones mainly because i still
have no idea what to do with them
um no actually makes sense to me
uh you can have one night alone with
adam driver john oliver voice
crush my toes you unwashed buffalo
uh oh goodness that
that that has been a trip that's been a
journey that thing
the animaniacs reboot is coming this
friday it is to hulu
which i don't have so i won't see it
ah
have you seen hamilton more than three
times on disney plus no it's still just
the three
i've been doing other stuff as opposed
to re-watching things that i
have already seen what do you think
authors should keep in mind when writing
a gender fluid person is there a trope
you hate in that regard i don't know if
there's too many tropes
around genderfluid people because
there's so little representation
of them generally if you're dealing with
a gender fluid character you're dealing
with like a demigod or an alien or
something that isn't just a person i
actually can't think i haven't
personally seen any um
gender fluid human gender fluid
characters
in media i just i haven't
but the closest i've seen is like
questioning characters like um
i think his name was sam the kid in uh
the riches
so i don't think there are necessarily
uh tropes that you need to watch out for
uh i would say the best thing to do is
to speak
to as many gender fluid people as are
willing to talk to you
because i cannot imagine that my
experience as a genderfluid person is
is in any way definitive or
representative of everybody's and i
i actually one of these days i gotta
find some other gender fluid people to
talk to
and like compare notes cause like i've
got i i
have plenty of people i know who are
binary trans or who are
non-binary or are um
demisexual or what have you
um but that i don't
i i have one friend who might be gender
fluid but they don't
really formally identify that way so
like i
i don't i don't feel comfortable just
asking that
but i don't know
what's frobisher in other than holy
terror bunch of comics
and there's an audio called the maltese
penguin which i haven't heard so i can't
vouch for that one
um shag marry kill
howard the duck darkwing duck daffy duck
oh
shag daffy marry dark wing kill howard
i am the terror that flaps in the night
i am the used chewing gum that sticks to
your shoe
i am darkwing duck
ah that was a good show
three seasons of one day at a time are
on netflix well i'll add it to my watch
list
no promises about when i get to it i
really cannot be starting anything new
that i'm not that i haven't been
commissioned for because i'm so far
behind on commission reviews
it's embarrassing
who's worse jar jar binks or gergie from
the black cauldron
gergie because the film mercifully
killed him and then
brought him back
like that that is what was really cruel
about the black cauldron he was there he
was awful
he died and then he came back
damn it gergie you can't even die right
spit when i said that
oh my goodness have you heard that
darkwing dunk is potentially getting a
reboot on disney plus i did hear i'm
waiting to hear if they're tying it into
the um new ducktales or if it's going to
be standalone
uh
it's all right thank you for giving it a
chance well thank you for bringing to my
attention
uh kiss mary killed the absorbable off
pating
and zygon
have to use each option for each
character
i'm not even entirely sure what you mean
by that when did this
when did the stream become a game of
kiss mary kill
uh what's worse ghostbusters 2 or
ghostbusters 2016 ghostbusters 2.
it's way worse it's not even close i
don't like
ghostbusters 2016 that much but
it's better than that
re-watched v for vendetta on november
the fifth the fact that v
and ev were dancing to anthony and the
johnsons left me with
questions i don't know them so i don't
know
i don't if you're getting at something
specific i don't know what it is
what are your thoughts on hallmark
christmas movies i'm sure they're lovely
for other people
if i ever do another drama class i'm
going to request to do this
icon inversion speech for my scene ooh
bold
uh the sad thing is that the absorbable
off wasn't funny but he was played by
one of the funniest comedians in britain
i've heard that i've have not seen the
evidence
um i'm going to give a break on the shag
mary kill folks it's been fun but i'm
going to
break on that favorite new who musical
moment
um
see the my my go-to answer is a
cheat because i love
the song my angel put the devil in me
from
daleks and manhattan which is done as
like a big showgirl number
which i love except the version they do
in the episode of the show is sung by
the actress
who's putting on this terrible fake new
york
new york accent i'm a country girl
oh god it's awful the soundtrack version
of that song
sung properly is amazing
but i don't like it actually in the show
nearly as much because
because of her voice my god
so bad i doubt it but did you listen to
my audio series i have not had the time
so no i i have not
if someone was to make a movie of you
what would be a better title than
council of geeks the movie um
i don't know it depends on if you were
trying to go cheeky or poignant
i feel like the poignant um
name for my life movie would be the
scenic route
because that's my life taking the scenic
route to get to wherever the heck i'm
doing do that tallulah impression again
no
uh doctor put your hands in the air
you had me oh god so bad
have you watched batman beyond uh only
bits and pieces
what are your thoughts on potentially
getting a movie with michael keaton
um that's only been a rumor so i have no
real thought
on it like it'd be cool but that's about
it
trans women are a staple in the drag
community before covid that was my
second job how do you feel about rupaul
excluding trans women from trans women
from drag race
i i have a lot of problems with that
uh and like increasingly so as
time goes on because
look i i have baggage around the
drag sort of community anyways
just because i felt very
excluded and you know i i did or i tried
to do
drag before i did burlesque and
and granted like this is all this is 10
year old information this is
all out of date um hopefully
but certainly at the time that i was
trying to
um get into drag
it was very exclusionist and now i
identified as cis at the time but i was
being excluded because
i was engaged to a woman
so the thing that was being used to keep
me
at arm's length was the fact that i
wasn't gay
i understand that drag
performance and drag culture is rooted
in gay
cisgender men i understand that's where
it comes from
but as an art form
i do not buy that
as a justification for excluding
people who aren't both of those things
and that's before you even get into the
weird politics
of drag or like there's drag houses and
you need a drag mother
to introduce you otherwise you can't get
booked for freaking anything other than
amateur shows no matter how good you are
that's not to say that i was the best
thing ever i wasn't but
um and then
i feel like the excuse
and i'm gonna call it an excuse i almost
called it a rationale
it's not it's this is not the reason
that trans women are excluded from drag
but it's the excuse
given for why they are it's the idea
that they somehow have an advantage
because through facial feminization or
hormones or whatever they already look
kind of like women and so they have some
sort of advantage over
cis men who have to do more work
which is absurd on multiple levels
number one
there are plenty of cisgender guys with
very feminine features
and there are plenty of trans women with
masculine features
so first of all you stereotyping so
that's
there's your first problem second of all
drag queens don't look like cis women
trans women day to day for most trans
women that i have known
their goal and their hope is to be
passable as a cis
woman which is not the same thing as a
drag queen
drag queens do not look
like the kind of thing that trans women
are trying to look like in their
day-to-day lives
and it's the same reason that honestly
cis women have as much right to be drag
queens
i have known cisgender female drag
queens who were
amazing the
look is so over the top and so
constructed i don't care who you
are i don't care what your base starting
level is
you have to do just as much work for the
makeup and the
outfits and the hair no matter what you
start from
that's one of the two rationales given
the other one being this
sense of appropriation of quote unquote
gay culture
but drag by its nature is already
appropriative
it's appropriating of feminine culture
and it's kind of hard to justify that
other people
can't take part in your already
appropriative
art form and drag is an art form don't
get me wrong
but come on
ah i went off a little bit there
more than i had um intended to
can't watch as i'm doing work in five
hours oh well thank you very much oh
god see if i can try and say this
if that if that's how it's intended to
be pronounced if it's meant to be
pronounced at all
sometimes with these with these names i
don't know
thank you very much sock puppet mogwai
um
have your thoughts on the timeless
children or the pre-heart no doctors
changed
and uh any and how or why um
not really um
i still hate the timeless child i hate
especially that it's the doctor
i hate that more than anything the fact
that
there are pre-heart no regenerations i
still don't
like it but i've kind of gotten
over it i'm not as that isn't actively
bothering me as much
i just kind of sat with the idea for a
while i'm like hey
whatever i still don't like it but it's
like
it's harder for me to justify that but i
still hate that the doctor's a timeless
child
i don't i have a hard time seeing any
scenario in which i
stop hating that idea
and i am gonna try and wrap it up soon
tallulah's actress uh miranda rayson is
currently a sixth doctor companion and
big finish
uh not uh not until the newer ak more
expensive stuff
unfortunately oh interesting
audio 6 doctor or 12th doctor well the
12 isn't on audio yet so i don't know
how he does there
scenario clara's confirmed to return
under chimnal's run what's your reaction
is your health ben take two reviews
passionate as your ranking worst moffitt
episodes
review tune in when it drops and find
out
uh
the council of geeks live stream without
a passionate rant it's like a bicycle
without its wheels
uh
i have a better title for your movie
either this is me or wild
[Laughter]
uh favorite performance from a doctor
who actor outside of the show
um
hmm
probably david tennant in jessica jones
all right i do need to wrap up and you
and you have bombarded me with questions
i'm actually gonna try and have one of
my characters sing uh devil and me for
her origin
story interesting um if you
had to travel in bill and ted's phone
booth what historical dudes would you
pick up
uh i don't know they'd have to be
english speakers i don't have the
patience
forgive me for not knowing but why are
people saying fire chip no
because they're because they're bitter
and they don't know how to
deal with anything other than to scream
make it what i want
would you want a doctor who musical
episode not really
uh the lead singer is a trans woman with
the most incredible voice so the fact
that
the band exists in the v for vendetta
universe which suggests that she didn't
survive
oh dang
so my doctor was in a bit of trouble
recently you could say he was in
distress
ben
don't push it
uh i think i might have messages you get
to the discord oh
jeez ah
care oh god caroline you've been yelling
at me i'm so so
i'm so sorry you know what the problem
was
like and this is an excuse this is this
oh god carowind i'm so sorry that you
had to yell at me
oh but um
the prob the last two times that we've
done it it
uh it was it was the
the live reactions stuff so i got out of
the habit
okay sorry questions from the discord
then i need to wrap
up um even though moulin rouge is one of
my favorite movies i always try to
understand why someone may not like
something i do
i can completely understand why someone
will be turned off by the editing and
the cover sums but i'm struggling
to understand what it is about christian
you don't like can you explain further
christians as [ __ ]
he's a manipulative judgmental [ __ ]
who thinks he knows what love is and
doesn't its obsession at best and he
puts this woman on a pedestal
and treats her like garbage the instant
the instant she does not live up to his
ideals of what love is supposed to be
he's an entitled prick
ah he's a creep do not like him
are you planning on watching his dark
material season two i didn't even finish
season one
i know you watched season one wondering
if you'll review season two see the
thing is i did the first i think
four episodes this evening season seven
season one cause i was commissioned to
i didn't keep going because i didn't
care that much
um what do you do when you feel like
you're burnt out or lost to join content
you used to love
uh could use some help in regard
personally so
um i'm assuming you mean in in content
creation
and
that's um
see i unless you're unless you share my
squirrel brain
i may not be the best person to ask
because the thing is i usually have so
many
projects going on and so many things i
am
literally in the middle of doing that
if i'm not feeling something i'll move
to something else
if i'm not feeling shooting i will edit
if i'm not feeling editing i'll watch
something that i need to do a review on
and take some notes if i'm not
up for that i will do some writing if
i'm not up for writing i will
put on an outfit and do a little self
photo shoot if i'm not up for that i'll
go for a walk
you know i the list of things that i
can and will do with my time is so
lengthy i i haven't
ever really hit the point of burn out
with everything
so i i don't really know how to answer
that
again just because the way my brain
works i may not be the best person to
ask
just notice that tenant um
was in call of duty world war ii zombies
somehow it sounds like his accent is
stereotypical scottish
oh my goodness that's not somewhere i
would have expected him to turn up
okay i think i think i'm done now
okay
[Laughter]
miss wiga wolf i i i see you i i see you
with the the hercules mulligan
i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do
it because i don't i can't do that
that bit as well um
let's see
ah i have discovered my doctor
being not caring about their appearance
and just wearing pajama bottoms
a white hoodie sweatshirt and a pair and
a pair of vans
whatever works uh
thoughts on the abominable bride episode
of sherlock particularly the
twist at the one hour mark i kind of
liked it
like it's it's jarring especially for
what the show had been up to that point
but
i i kind of liked it
i haven't rewatched it in a while so i
can't be more substantive than that but
i don't know why but in recent years
i've found matt smith's doctor more
forgettable is that weird
um i don't know i mean well first of all
thank you randomness
um
i don't know i mean i i don't think it's
um
unusual for your opinions to shift with
time how they shift
will vary that just kind of happens
what are your thoughts on the tv show
house starring hugh laurie
um it
it never got truly bad but it
it started declining after series four
series four season four american
tv uh
who's more powerful bruce almighty or
bill murray from groundhog's day
well bill murray can't actually do
anything
he's just stuck he doesn't actually have
powers
vera pay attention oh god what am i
missing now
oh
carowind i think you might have to
punish me later
[Laughter]
uh okay let's see do you have any
suggestions
uh one trying to come out to a partner
do you think that doing it through an
email or letter to hand him is too
impersonal
um that
that's really difficult um
to answer and i think a lot of it's
gonna depend
on you as a person
um and also your partner
who i'm going to refer to as him because
you do in the question so that's
me kind of presuming but
if
if the nature of your relationship
either you personally or
how he'll be able to process you think
would be better facilitated
by doing it that way then like it's a
viable option i wouldn't tell you not to
do it
my general recommendation with
coming out to anyone who you
aren't completely confident in
what their reaction will be is to
if possible
um have someone else who does already
know
in the room not necessarily for the
whole conversation
but initially basically has emotional
support
but of course that begs the question as
to whether or not you are out to anyone
other than your significant other yet
which obviously i
don't know um
the thing is there's no
there's no guide on how to come out
there's no right or wrong way
to do it because it's going to vary
depending on
you what works for you what
you are comfortable with and also with
the people you're coming out to and you
may have to adjust how you approach
things depending on
what they're like and these things are
all so
specific to your experience in your life
that it's it's hard
for me to give general advice because it
is
the the true proper answer is going to
be so personalized
to you that
i i can't give broad
advice on it other than
just think
on what it is you want to say
if it's easier for you to write it down
and hand it to him or to write it down
and read
it off a letter so that you know your
your thoughts are gathered that's
something you could do
if those things will help then do them
and if you think it's going to throw him
off that you're doing that rather than
talking to him
explain that in the email or the letter
as well
say i this may not be the way you want
to hear this but
this was the way that was more most
comfortable to me like let him in
that's going to be the big thing coming
out to someone isn't just about
saying to them hey i'm whatever it is
you are
it's about letting them in
not just on your identity but on
your feelings your emotions your
thoughts
so however you choose to come out
is absolutely fine
depending on what it is
you may want to include an explanation
for why you're doing it that way if you
think that that's something that
might throw them off but you're still
allowed to do it
however is going to work best for you
i went on for a while and kind of
circled the same points
i don't know how helpful that was i'm so
sorry you had to ask the question so
many times
and that caroline had to yell at me
thank you again carowind
very much um
i don't know if that helped but i hope
so and
i wish you the best of luck
i really do however it goes
it's going to be scary
but
i will hope for the best outcome for you
so i think um
i need to wrap it up i need to do a
quick
check on something here
um
let's see
so i'm just making sure that i didn't
miss anything oh thank you very much
john i knew there was a super chat i
missed
um thank you very much for that
why are you dressed up as wonder woman
because i
can
uh
okay yeah we're going to wrap it up
there
oh you and you're welcome
so i hope everyone is
staying safe uh especially in a lot of
possible parts of the world right now
we have to go back to drastic measures
in order to do that
but remember that no matter what you are
going through
no matter what is going on no matter
how alone you might feel
sometimes i want you
to remember that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council and i only run the
meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
my cavity